There are two major types of malware.
The first kind of malware needs
host program, meaning that
they have to be embedded in the host
program in order to run and spread.
The second type of malware is
independent, meaning that they themself
are independent programs
that can run by themself.
We will study some of
them in this lecture and
cover the rest in the next lecture.
When we say a malware
needs a host program,
we mean that the malware is
embedded in the existing program so
that you can enter program, runs on
the system and then spread from there.
There are several ways for
malware to imbed itself into a program.
For example, trap doors,
logic bombs, trojan horses,
viruses, and malicious browser plugins
and extensions and scripts and so on.
And the independent malware
does not need a host program,
because this malware are complete
programs by themself.
Examples of these malware include worms,
botnets,
and advanced persistent threats,
or APTs.
We will discuss botnets and
APTs in a later lesson.